[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 26 minutes d'édition
préparé par la rédaction
pour revenir sur l'ensemble de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce mardi 27 février
le salon de l'agriculture se poursuit
jusqu'à dimanche à la porte de
versailles à paris cette année encore
l'île de france est présente pour
promouvoir la production locale
le stand a été inaugurée hier entretien
à suivre dans ce journal également suite
de notre dossier de la semaine consacrée
aux producteurs des yvelines
comme chaque mardi le portrait de la
rédaction à 26 ans est l'un des plus
jeune dompteur d'europe michael douchet
se produit actuellement à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
ils assurent les spectacles de fauves du
cirque nicolas zavatta en représentation
sur le territoire jusqu'à demain
mercredi
enfin c'est un corps de ballet uniques
au monde créés par bartabas en 2003
l'académie équestre national du domaine
de versailles est reparti pour son
programme annuel
un spectacle mêlant dressage chant danse
escrime et l'art japonais du kyudo avant
de développer à ses titres des
températures polaires venus de l'est la
france a connu aujourd'hui est la
journée la plus froide de la semaine
quelques flocons sont même tombés 69
départements dont les yvelines ont
activé leur plan grand froid en pratique
il permet l'ouverture de places
supplémentaires en hébergement pour les
sans abri en ile de france 1960 et est
ainsi ouverte depuis jeudi les équipes
du samu social sont renforcés les
associations mobilisées comme ce
collectif de jeunes saint quentinois et
que nous avons reçu hier la marche à
suivre même des maraudes à paris et ce
tous les week-ends et une question que
beaucoup se posent comment la météo
va-t-elle évoluer leur dos et il pour
bientôt mais quel ennemi draw nicolas
kirillovitch et quentin le frère sont
allés à glaner quelques prévisions du
côté du centre météo france à trappes
températures glaciales neige le port du
bonnet sera-t-il obligatoire dans les
prochains jours nous allons poser toutes
ces questions au centre météorologique
est ici à trappes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
ad côté emmanuel vers prévisionnistes
ici au centre météo france emmanuel est
ce que ça va perdurer cette vague de
froid alors encore jusqu'à demain on
attend des températures relativement
basses même très près ce qu'ils
descendront dans la nuit prochaine de
nouveaux verres moins six à moins 9
degrés et avec le vent ça fera une
sensation encore plus froides et des
températures ressenties de l'an de -10 à
moins 12 mois très souvent moins 14
degrés suivant l'intensité du vent
ensuite on attend un radoucissement
progressif au cours de la journée de
jeudi et surtout à partir de vendredi et
le week-end prochain
est ce que c'est un phénomène
exceptionnel alors qu'on vient en ce
moment pour l'hiver non c'est pas
exceptionnel mais c'est vrai que ça
arrive pas tous les ans ce genre de
périodes de froid aussi intense
là c'est vrai que depuis plusieurs jours
on a des températures qui sont très
inférieures aux normales de saison
surtout depuis lundi et on a atteint un
minimum dans la nuit dernière avec des
températures qui était déjà proche du
moins six à moins huit degrés un peu
partout sur le département
et ça devrait se reproduire dans l'année
prochaine c'est un phénomène qui se voit
une fois tous les dix ans on peut le
dire la d1 face à terre en mars 2005
alors effectivement on mars 2005
on avait eu une période de froid entre
guillemets un peu tardive et intense là
ça se produit en fin février et tous les
dix ans et pas forcément régulier mais
ça se reproduit
régulièrement comment on fait pour
prévenir ce type de rendez-vous avec le
froid alors pour prévenir ou pour
prévoir donc pour prévoir ce genre
d'événement on a des modèles de
prévision numérique qui nous donne
l'évolution du temps pour les dix jours
qui viennent voir un peu plus loin si on
veut mais plus on essaie de voir loin
dans le temps et moins les prévisions
sont précises et il ya également un
épisode neigeux qui s'annonce jeudi
alors effectivement on a un épisode
neigeux qui devrait mettre un terme à
cette vague de froid et qui est attendu
à partir de la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi et jeudi dans la
matinée ou en cours de cette matinée la
neige devrait être progressivement
remplacés par de la pluie pluie
verglaçante dans un premier temps et
puis à priori à partir de la mi journée
dans l'après midi on devrait avoir de la
pluie seul qui ne verrait glace plus et
donc ne provoque plus de phénomènes
glissants lé jeu va t elle tenir sur les
routes cette année je vais tenir dans la
nuit de mercredi à jeudi puisque les
températures seront encore très froide
et les sols seront gelés jeudi matin on
aura encore certainement une tenue au
sol puisque
les températures resteront négatives et
ce qui sera à surveiller surtout jeudi
matin ce sera le passage en pluie
verglaçante
qu'il a
pourront donner des sols très glissants
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra enlever le beau
et élégant pour ce week-end
alors pour ce week end oui normalement
on devrait plus avoir de geler des
températures positives du matin jusqu'au
soir
donc à partir la semaine prochaine on
peut dire que c'est bon alors même à
partir de
vendredi et plus tôt samedi on va
retrouver des températures de saison qui
évolueront en gros entre 2 et 10 degrés
et du coup au mois de mars
on ne sait plus pour les 20 500
un début de mois de mars dans les normes
de saison au niveau des températures
merci manuel vert plus d'informations
sur le site météo france points comme le
froid devrait persister encore pendant
deux jours voilà pour les prévisions
quelques conseils aussi à adopter face
aux grands froids habillez vous
chaudement idéalement en trois couches
de vêtements avec une couche extérieure
imperméable couvrez-vous la tête le nez
et les mains de retour à l'intérieur
alimenter vous convenablement et prenez
une boisson chaude ne surchauffez pas
votre logement et surtout ne bouchez pas
les entrées d'air de votre habitation à
penser enfin à l'aérés quelques minutes
chaque jour et même avec ce froid et si
vous voyez une personne en difficulté
dans la rue contacter le samu social ont
composant le 115 dans l'actualité
également le salon de l'agriculture
continue à porte de versailles à paris
vous le verrez tout à l'heure un stand
ile-de-france est présent sur
l'événement et toute cette semaine
justement le dossier de la rédaction est
consacrée à l'agriculture du département
suite ce soir avec deux gourmands de
producteurs de biscuits yvelinois il
fabrique des gâteaux des pains d'épicés
ou encore du miel des denrées vendues
dans les supermarchés
elle met aussi directement à la ferme
découverte avec patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas kirillovitch du
biscuit et du miel médine yvelines dans
un rayon de supermarché ou la rencontre
de la grande distribution et du local
avec un équilibre gagnant gagnant a
trouvé entre la direction du magasin et
le producteur
c'est lui qui est venu me voir alors
après très souvent nous ont fait des
recherches
on va visiter un peu les les artisans du
coin là c'est lui qui de nous voir avec
ces biscuits qu'on a goûté qu'on a adoré
le but c'est de bâtir un tarif ensemble
donc on réfléchit le juge de paix c'est
payant toujours donc le bon prix c'est
le prix que le client est prêt à payer
pour une qualité une production locale
dont les secrets sont gardés dans cette
ferme à crêpière par les deux gourmands
biscuits miel et pain d'épicés d'abord
vendu dans cette boutique les relations
avec la grande distribution se
sont-elles construite dans un second
temps je pense que pour travailler
avec les anciennes et lesquels on
travaille il fallait être prêt
c'est-à-dire être capable de répondre à
une demande un peu plus importante
maintenant faut quand même savoir que la
grande distribution peut travailler en
direct avec des petits producteurs comme
nous ce qui rend finalement la chose
plus facile
installé depuis cinq ans guillaume
caffin et louis bataille ont commencé
leur activité avec la fabrication de
biscuits à partir de matières premières
locales valeurs essentielles des deux
gourmands
le point de départ c'est vraiment la
région ces terroirs et de d'apporter un
peu plus ce qui manque dans
l'agroalimentaire selon nos deux de
transparence de proximité et devrait la
fabrication du miel est né de la
rencontre entre les deux entrepreneurs
et l'apiculteur antoine édoin il y a
trois ans ils sont aujourd'hui associé
le miel est récoltée au printemps et en
été il est ensuite travaillé lors de
l'hiver ici on a la garantie est de
proposer aux consommateurs amiel qui est
uniquement retravailler à froid et qui
donc va garder l'entièreté de ses
propriétés telles que celles que vous
avez dans les ruches
j'ai eu cette volonté de me rapprocher
du consommateur de pouvoir expliquer
comme je le fais aujourd'hui
la particularité de mes produits ma
façon de travailler le fait qu'on puisse
produire des produits de qualité en ile
de france aux portes de paris on peut
avoir des des miels brut qui sont
véritablement le symbole de nos terroirs
du gâtinais de fleurs ou de forêts
différents types de produits qui rendent
mielleuse la boutique des deux gourmands
est la suite de notre fil rouge de
demain mercredi avec un sujet sur
l'agriculture yvelinoise connectés près
de 570 mille hectares de terres
cultivées 4000 exploitations l ile de
france certes urbaine dans sa proche
banlieue est aussi une région agricole
aux multiples productions
un exemple dans la région on cultive le
blé
la beauce véritable grenier de
l'hexagone la filière céréalière
francilienne emploie 43 mille personnes
un terroir et des exploitants qui sont
mises en avant cette année encore au
salon de l'agriculture sur le stand du
servie à paris ile de france c'est le
centre régional de valorisation et
d'innovation agricole et alimentaire
l'espace a été inauguré hier à lundi en
présence de la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse
camille lambert et nicolas landry l'ont
rencontré nous sommes ici au salon de
l'agriculture et la présidente de la
région ile de france valérie pécresse
vient d'inaugurer le stand ile de france
bonsoir alors déjà un mot sur le cervia
je suppose aussi un outil important pour
la région ile de france par rapport à sa
politique agricole
bien sûr c'est un outil crucial parce
que ce que nous voulons aujourd'hui
c'est qu' il y ait plus d'identité et
plus de proximité c'est à dire que les
franciliens veulent manger local et ils
savent que les productions qui sont
faites tout près de chez eux à leur
porte et bien sont de bonne qualité sont
meilleurs et qu'en plus elles ont un
bilan carbone très favorable donc nous
avons besoin de leur donner à voir tout
ce qui est produit dans notre région
c'est pour ça que nous créons
aujourd'hui le label des agneaux
d'héberger d'île de france
parce que l'agneau d'ile-de-france en
réalité étaient connus depuis des
siècles et là c'est une filière qui est
en train de revivre de renaître et que
nous voulions donner à voir
particulièrement cette année alors
l'ile-de-france et 45 9 % de surfaces
agricoles c'est près de cinq mille
exploitations agricoles vous avez rien à
envier à d'autres régions la normandie
ou l'auvergne rhône-alpes
on le sait peu mais effectivement on
pense ile de france on pense urbain
alors que la moitié du territoire
francilien c'est des terres agricoles et
des forêts donc on a aujourd'hui en
ile-de-france vraiment la possibilité de
monts
j'ai locales et nous allons travailler
cette année sur le produit le plus
emblématique de l'île de france
la baguette la baguette c'est le blé
franciliens c'est les boulangers de
paris c'est toute une filière que nous
allons mettre au service des cantines et
j'ai pris l'engagement que cette année
dans les lycées d'île de france tout le
pain serait du pain francilien on va
commencer avec le pain mais on va
poursuivre ensuite avec le mar les
produits maraîchers la ceinture
maraîchère de l'île de france est en
train de renaître
nous allons continuer avec le lait
puisque nous avons une grande filière
autour du bris qui est structuré dans la
seine et marne
bref nous allons petit à petit arriver à
100 % de produits locaux dont 50 % de
bio à l'horizon 2024 et c'est l'objectif
que vous êtes ceux fixés l'année
dernière lors d'une délibération au
conseil régional
concrètement comment ça va être mis en
place concrètement on développe des
filières je vous ai parlé de la filière
baguette la filière pan on va travailler
aussi avec la filière laitière pour
produire les yaourts et les fromages qui
sont nécessaires pour les cantines
ensuite on va travailler sur de la
transformation parce que pour les
éleveurs
eh bien nous n'avons très nous n'avons
pratiquement plus d'abattoir donc il
faut travailler sur une filière de
transformation y compris à la ferme
notamment pour les poulets pour les
lapins pour des peptides la petite
transformation et puis bien sûr
eh bien on va travailler sur cette
ceinture maraîchère de l'île de france
vous savez la fête de la fraise la fête
de la tomate le
le chou de pontoise l'aspergé
d'argenteuil tous et toutes ces ces
produits que nous avons oublié
aujourd'hui mais qui sont partie de
l'identité francilienne alors j'en
reviens aux chiffres sur le nombre
d'exploitations agricoles
on voit que sur 10 ans il ya une baisse
de 22% est ce qu'on a besoin de rendre
plus attractif le métier agricole alors
nous y travaillons il faut aider
évidemment les jeunes agriculteurs à
s'installer
parce qu'être un agriculteur s'être à
l'entrepreneur c'est donc prendre des
risques et les risques sont importants
surtout au démarrage notamment avec les
aléas climatiques le réchauffement
les inondations qui peuvent porter entre
un coup très dur à des jeunes
entrepreneurs qui s'installe donc la
région on va les aider
elle va les aider en faisant le portage
foncier de leur terre c'est à dire leur
permettant de n'acquérir leurs terres
que progressivement pas tout de suite
pas au démarrage
elle va leur donner aussi un chèque pour
les achètent conseil pour les clés
tutoré pendant les deux ou trois
premières années pour leur apporter une
expertise technique dont ils ont besoin
en lien avec les jeunes agriculteurs et
donc nous allons travailler vraiment
pour que les agriculteurs puissent aussi
moderniser leurs exploits exploitation
tout ça avec les aides de la région
concrètement vous allez payer sur
plusieurs années le début de charges par
rapport aux terres en fête agricole pour
les jeunes agriculteurs
c'est exactement ça et puis on va aussi
leur donner des aides à l'installation
qui ont été qui ont été augmentés parce
que c'est vraiment dans la jeunesse que
nous avons l'avenir de l'agriculture
francilienne la plupart des jeunes qui
s'installent la majorité de jeunes qui
s'installent ont un projet
diversification c'est à dire que les
parents faisaient des grandes cultures
des céréales des betteraves du colza
le jeune agriculteur qui arrive lui il a
envie de faire du maraîchage il a envie
de faire
2 du miel il a envie de faire des
produits transformés
donc en réalité il change la nature de
l'exploitation plus en direction du
consommateur local et c'est exactement
ce qu'attend les franciliens valérie
pécresse merci et les visiteurs ont donc
jusqu'au dimanche 4 mars pour venir
découvrir les producteurs et
agriculteurs d'île de france
entretien réalisé par camille lambert et
nicolas landry au salon de l'agriculture
à saint quentin en yvelines une première
attrape un centre de bien-être orientale
a ouvert en face de la mairie au début
du mois de février
ce mardi après-midi le maire de la
commune guy malandain est venu
rencontrer les propriétaires
l'élu a eu le droit à une visite guidée
du centre 220 m² qui accueille déjà plus
de 80 et clients par semaine
le bien-être un créneau sur lequel la
ville compte s'appuyer pour diversifier
ses commerces propos collectées au micro
de michael et demi d'euros ça n'existait
pas un trappe et donc quand la demande
d'installation est ici rue jaurès est
arrivé on on a donné notre accord
c'est ouvert à tout le monde et je pense
que chacun y trouvera son bonheur en
revenant est ici que se reposer se faire
parfumer une bonne détente physique et
intellectuelle le portrait de la semaine
est consacrée à un homme qui a passé une
partie de sa vie avec les fauves à 26
ans il reste le plus jeune dompteur
d'europe l'un des plus jeune dompteur
d'europe
michael est douchée consacre sa vie aux
animaux depuis à 14 ans le dresseur est
en tournée actuellement sur le circuit
nicolas zavatta il se produit à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à demain mercredi
portraits signés camille lambert et vous
avez trois tigres heures ou trois
tigresses en fait
roux vous avez une tigresse blanche
keira est là bas vous avez une lionne
couleurs formes et unyon blanche donc
mara emma fric il les appelle tendrement
ses filles pour michael douchet ces
animaux sont comme des enfants qu'il
faut élever et dont il faut prendre soin
chaque jour il passe du temps avec eux
dans la cage de détente une aire de jeux
et de repos leur terrible
ouah michael est le soleil être toléré
il est considéré comme le mâle dominant
la salle d'armes dans nos moeurs et
connaître les formes savoir l'accident
avant qu'il arrive
michael connaît chacun de leur caractère
et de leur aptitude un savoir qui lui a
permis de préparer son spectacle c'est
comme se dresser sur les pattes arrière
est qu'il offre naturellement on les
voit faire on regarde ce qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent faire et c'est là où on
apprend à faire pour le spectacle donc
il faut bien vraiment en faire
comprendre passer du temps avec eux et
y'a vraiment qu'avec des récompenses et
de la douceur qu'on arrive à faire plein
de choses
née au sein de la famille douchet du
cirque nicolas zavatta
michael a baigné depuis l'enfance au
plus près des félins avec son grand
frère dompteur fasciné par ces animaux
ils commençaient premier spectacle à 14
ans aujourd'hui à 26 ans il fait
toujours partie des plus jeune dompteur
d'europe
quelques heures avant le spectacle les
artistes répètent en place à l'est mais
les femelles sont encore des
adolescentes âgées de 1 à 6 ans parfois
un peu turbulente et pas toujours très à
l'aise
l'afrique est encore en phase
d'apprentissage une confiance instaurée
dès le plus jeune âge tous nés en
captivité certains fauves ont été élevés
au biberon quand la mère ne voulait pas
d'eux une éducation basée sur la
confiance et un système de récompenses
en morceaux de viande et en caresse pour
ceux qui les aiment comme koumaye le
spectacle commence bientôt tout doit
être prêt car c'est michael et ses
fauves qui ouvre le bal
[Musique]
le reste de la représentation se
poursuit et se termine avec ou my
michael contenu le spectacle car c'est
lui qui s'occupe de toute la ménagerie
du cirque une passion et un métier
souvent mal vu c'est vraiment une vie au
quotidien
on vit avec eux comme on vit avec nos
enfants donc on les aime on fait tout
pour qu'il soit le mieux possible
c'est vrai que j'écoute parfois dire des
choses il serait mieux dans la nature il
sera mieux on peut dire plein de choses
ici nous ont fait le mieux possible pour
qu'il soit bien on leur donne à manger
autant qu'ils en veulent tout le monde
peut venir voir justement où son dernier
mot et commençons à privilégier le
dialogue et le partage pour désamorcer
les tensions le cirque traditionnel avec
des animaux inventé il ya 250 ans reste
toujours un spectacle très demandé un
art à part entière interdit dans des
pays comme le danemark ou le mexique
un métier qu'il transmettra aux
générations suivantes si la législation
française le permet après un repos bien
mérité l'académie équestre de versailles
a rouvert ses portes les écuyers et
leurs montures ont repris le chemin du
manège pour leur spectacle répertoire la
voie de l'écuyer il mêle la discipline
du dressage le chant la danse les scream
et l'art japonais du kyudo mélanie
poquet et nicolas landry l'écuyer a
retrouvé sa voix envoûtante l'académie
équestre de versailles a repris le
spectacle imaginé par bartabas en 2003
ne cesse d'évoluer
en 2011 nous avons travaillé avec
carolyn carlson pour le spectacle we
were horses ou du coup on nous sommes
quasiment tous devenu danseur
nous montons en reine à la ceinture et
nous avons du coup les mains libres
donc depuis cette création nous avons
intégré ce tableau le dressage
traditionnels se mêlent à des
disciplines diverses
[Musique]
oh
au fil des années les écuyers deviennent
ainsi escrimeurs ou encore chanteur la
voie de l'écuyer c'est une mise en scène
d'une relation fusionnelle avec les
chevaux travailler dans le spectacle
équestre ça implique un investissement
quasi totale dans le sens où des le shaq
journée qu'on passe on doit consacrer
vraiment beaucoup d'écouté
et aussi beaucoup d'amour et beaucoup
d'attention au cheval qui est notre
outil de travail et qui est notre
compagnon aussi une relation cavaliers
monture à découvrir jusque dans les
coulisses de l'académie une visite avec
un conférencier 83 dates sont prévues
pour l'année 2018
[Musique]
oh
du sport foot us le week-end dernier
dans le froid les templiers d'elancourt
ont obtenu leur première victoire de la
saison en deuxième division
c'était une victoire face aux pionniers
de touraine les yvelinois avec qui ont
pu profiter de leur nouvelle recrue
américaine kiss reynolds aligné dès
l'entâme de la rencontre retour sur le
match mickaël et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry du sérieux et de la détermination
deux ingrédients qui ont permis aux
templiers d'elancourt de tenir leur rang
contre les pionniers de touraine lors de
la 4e journée du championnat de 2e
division
score final 21 6 première victoire de la
saison à domicile ou d'un gros jeu au
sol
c'est ça qui nous a permis de tenir le
match entre guillemets on prend pas
beaucoup de yards en défense donc on est
pas mal là dessus il faut qu'on
s'améliore un peu sur le déjà la passe
et puis qu'on soit plus efficace soit
même distance à voir ensemble à tout ce
qu'ils ont fait on l'avait vu à la vidéo
sur leurs deux premiers matches
y'a rien qui nous a vraiment surpris à
la fin du match il n'avait plus vraiment
de réponse à face à notre attaque donc
ils mettaient beaucoup de pression on a
réussi à inscrire que deux trois brèches
pour sombrer essence ce populeux de l'an
et ça a bien marché pour nous seul bémol
de ce match référence ce touch donne
encaissé en fin de match par les
templiers d'elancourt sous une
température glaciale une séquence de jeu
qui a eu tendance à agacer le staff de
l'équipe l'eau
quand le match passe bien on a tendance
à se relâcher et c'est vrai que si on
met par la glande sur la touche on a
vite fait de se disperser et c'est vrai
que faut que les gars se rappelle que
même si on est devant c'est important il
faut exécuter jusqu'au coup de sifflet
parce qu'on sait jamais ce qui peut se
passer
on a vécu trop de match catastrophe qui
sont retournés en deux minutes et on se
retrouve le bec dans l'eau à la fin du
match donc pourrait pas que ça se
reproduise au classement les tons pied
toujours invaincu reste deuxième de la
poule 2 ils sont toujours en course pour
les playoffs de fin de saison
prochain match le sel 10 80 sur le
terrain des corsaires débris avant de se
quitter rappel de quelques conseils
adopter face au grand froid qui sévit
actuellement dans les yvelines habillez
vous chaudement idéalement trois couches
de vêtements avec une couche extérieure
imperméable couvrez-vous la tête le nez
et les mains de retour à l'intérieur
alimenter vous convenablement et prenez
une boisson chaude elle ne surchauffez
pas votre logement et surtout ne bouchez
pas les entrées d'air de votre
habitation penser enfin à l'aérés
quelques minutes chaque jour et ce même
avec ce froid et si vous voyez une
personne en difficulté dans la rue
contacter le samu social 115 les équipes
du 115 a d'ailleurs acquis sont
renforcés avec le plan grand froid qui
reste activée en ile de france est et
dans les yvelines les associations
mobilisées sont également mobilisés
comme ce jeune collectif de saint
quentinois que nous avons reçu hier est
la marche à suivre qui mène des maraudes
à paris l'entretien comme l'ensemble de
ce journal et ses reportages est à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 voilà
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi et je vous souhaite une
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]